えー お肉を禁止して
1週間以上経ってるんですけども
なんか余裕です！
はじめしゃちょーです
なんか多分ね 魚を食べてるから
意外と全然 大丈夫です
そんな食べたいとも思わないし
まぁ焼肉には
死ぬほど行きたいです笑
はい！というわけで今日はですね
あの こちら
みなさん知ってますでしょうか
ルーブックキューブなんですけども
僕ほんとに なにも分かんないんですよ
なんか今まで
ルービックキューブって
できたらかっこいいなとか
思ってたんですけども
1度も解ける気がしない
1面ぐらいならいけます
ちょっと わっ！
何で 今 引っ付いたんだろう？
ちょ 今からどれか揃えます
じゃ 黄色揃えますね
よーいどん！
【ヘルマン・ネッケ作曲「クシコス・ポスト」】
はい はい、はい はい はい はい
えー くるりんときて
こうしてこう
だぁーい！
2分ぐらいかかりました
後はごちゃごちゃです笑
いやー1面ぐらいなら
全然行けるんすよ
僕の頭脳だったらね
ただもう2面とかになると
ほんとに無理なんで
ちょっとあと揃えてみましょうか
よーいどん！
逃がしが通用しなくなるんだよな
【ヘルマン・ネッケ作曲「クシコス・ポスト」】
あー無理だめだ  よくないよくない
だって赤動かそうとしたら
黄色がだめになるんすよ
なんかこういうめっちゃ早い人
いるじゃないすか  こういう
あれになりたい
あれになりたいんですけども
正直んーーー
昔1日かけてやろうと思ったんですよ
なんかテキトーにやってたら
できるかなと思ったんですけども
断じて無理でした
多分  僕の脳みそだと  無理！
というわけで今日の企画は
もう何としてでも
ルービックキューブを
とりあえず揃えようという企画です
ごめんなさい
ほんとに僕が揃えたいだけです
ほんとに知識のない人でも
攻略とかなんか
ネットの情報とかあるんでそれを見て、
バカがルーブックキューブを
全面揃えるのに
どれだけの時間がかかるのか
調べて行きたいと思います
まじで知識ないですよ ほんとに
なんで 僕が今なんか
ネットの情報とか
いろんなのをすべて駆使して
これを9面(6面)揃えれた
タイムだったら
多分みなさんもできると思うので
ぜひ 試してみてはいかがでしょうか
では 計っていきます
よーい...
【ﾋﾟｰｰｰｰｰ】
えーっと まず、えっと えっと
えー すげえ ルービックキューブを
6面 揃えられる人は
全世界で6%しかいないみたいです
こんなん言ってる場合じゃない！！
えー 待ってどうすればいいんだろ？
「ズル技」「裏技」「最短手順」
そう！それそれそれそれ！
なになになに？
えっ むー え、待って待って
ほんとに難しいじゃん！
待って パターンがあるの？
「独立型」「間接型」「セット型」
「逆再生型」
ふっ ふっ ふっ ふっ
なんか いろんなパターンがあるから
必ずこれをやればできるっていうのが
ないらしいですね
助けて
やばい なにも分からん 難しすぎる
なに R  F  R'  F  F  R
F  R2  R2  F R  F
待って ほんとにヘルプなんだけど
なにも分かんない！
落ち着け 落ち着け！
まずは1面 揃えることからってこと？
いや 1面ぐらいは
ほんとにいるんだってば！
なんか 1面 揃え方は分かるんですよ
でも多分それしか
できないぐらいなんすよね
逃がして、入れて
あっ きたきた！
はい！
いや それは分かったんすよ！
だから1面はできるんすよ！
だからこっからなんすよ！
1回 白揃えよっか
逃がして 逃がして 入れてゆく！
はい！
まあ 1面は全然できるんすよね
なんか いけそうな気がします
道を見つけました
【Now Fighting】
あっ ×8
なんかいけそう！なんかいけそう！
わあ！ あっ なんか なんかなんか
おっ？×3
待って、本気で
スピードなんだよな
え 待って ほんとに難しいんですけど
【Now Fighting】
やばい！
日が暮れちまう！
待って やばい 難しい
難しいな これ
ちょっと舐めてましたわ
やばい やったわ
ちょっとやり直します
だめだ 難しすぎる
電池切れた！
【Now Fighting】
あっ！終わった！
終わった それは終わった！
【Now Fighting】
なるほど なるほど
分かってきたぞ 分かってきたぞ
そういう仕組みか
おっ ×6
【はじめ過呼吸】
いける！いける！
上の2段目までは全部 揃えました
いけるぞ！
あれ？これ もうやばくね結構
【Now Fighting】
【はじめ過呼吸】
うわー これむずいな
ここまできて最後が難しいやつだ これ
【Now Fighting】
やばい どうしよう
おかし…
おかしくなった
おかしくなっちゃった×4
えっ えっ えっと…
えっ待って おかしくなっちゃった！
【Now Fighting】
OK OK OK…
あっ あっ あっ あっ 揃ってる揃ってる！
待って待って えっ えっ えっ えっ
あっ あっ あっ あっ あっ あっ
すごい しゅごい、もう もう
もう目前 もう目前
あれ
おかしくなっちゃったよ
せーい、せい
はっ はっ はっ はっ はっ
いや慌てるな こっからが難しいんですよ
俺は知ってる
ここからがきついということを
【Now Fighting】
あまり変なことすんなよ俺
戻れなくなるぞ
おい 待て 大丈夫か
おい やめろ 変なことすんな俺
やめろよ 変なことするんじゃないよ
やばい やったか？
あー！！まただーーー！！！！！
あーーー
待って俺 ほんとにこれやばい
ふーーーーー
【Now Fighting】
待って こっからなんだよ
こっからが怖いんだよ こっからが
【Now Fighting】
やばい もう もうできそうなんですけど
最後の詰めがまじで難しい気がする
【Now Fighting】
えっ おかしい おかしい おかしい
なんで なんで なんで
うわっ もう待って
やばい やったかも
やったかも やったかも やばい！
やばい！やった やったかも！
やばい！よくない よくない！
戻したい 戻したい
あっ待って だめだ！だめだ！
やばい だめだ！無理無理無理！
無理無理無理！
これ以上 無理！これ以上 無理！
無理だよ！
分かんない 分かんない 分かんない
誰？×5
【Now Fighting】
はっ はっ はっ はっ はっ
もういける！もういける！
まじいける！まじいける！まじいk...
来たか これ！
いきます！
こう
こう こう
こう こう こう
こう
はっ はっ はっ はっ はっ はっ はっ
【はじめ過呼吸】
できたーーー！！！！！！
タイム タイム タイム タイム
タイムは？
えっ はぁっ！
【ED】